hey this is press tow
Walker year after year some viral
equation gets spread across the internet
dividing people up into groups and
everyone is arguing about what the
correct answer is I'm so happy to cover
these topics and to clear up
misconceptions here's another problem
that came across my desk what is 8 / 2
multiplied 4 equal 2 the answer choices
are 1 16 4 none of the above or there is
no correct answer it is ambiguous and
poorly
written what do you think the correct
answer
is let's work it out by using the modern
interpretation of the order of
operations this is commonly remembered
as pemos this refers to parentheses then
exponents multiplication and division
and addition
subtraction you could also remember it
as as bodmas where we have brackets and
orders if you have two operators of the
same precedence evaluate them from left
to right so in this expression we have
only multiplication and division which
are of the same precedent so we want to
evaluate them from left to right so we
start with 8 / 2 which is equal to
4 then we have four multiplied 4 and
that gives the correct answer of 16 this
is without a doubt the correct answer
according to the modern interpretation
of the order of
operations now let's just go back in
time a little bit to the year
1917 I came across this paper
discussions relating to the order of
operations in algebra and this was
published in the American mathematical
monthly which was first published in
1894 it's quite amazing that something
could still be published that was
started in
1894 interestingly they covered exactly
this
topic in case the signs of
multiplication and division occur the
operations are to be performed in the
order from left to right in fact this
very question appears in the paper 8 / 2
multiplied 4 you need to evaluate 8 / 2
and then multiply by 4 to get 16 and
this is not 8 divided by the group term
2 multiplied 4 that would be equal to
one a series of operations involving
multiplication and division alone shall
be performed in the order in which they
occur from left to right so this should
settle matters
forever but interestingly there is
always an exception that proves the rule
for years I've been asking asking
someone to provide a reference to a
historical usage many people have said
well I've learned that if I've seen
multiplication and division we would
take the left side and divide it by the
right side in other words
multiplications are done before Division
and I want to thank Pete for actually
providing me with a reference this comes
from a textbook that he used and he
saved and he actually took a picture and
sent it to
me when there are no symbols of grouping
in an expression it is understood that
multiplication is performed first
division next and addition or
subtraction last so here we have 32 / 4
multiplied 2 and specifically the author
says you need to do 4 multiplied two
first to get 8 and then 32 / 8 is equal
to 4 and they said don't do it the other
way now this is the first time I've
actually seen a printed reference
that shows this example and I'm so
grateful to see it so people who said
they learned it another way it is
definitely possible you should never
dismiss that they did learn it this
other way so what would be the answer by
this
convention we would need to do 2
multiplied 4 first and that gives eight
substituting that in we have 8 divided
by 8 which is equal to 1 and that would
be the answer according to this
interpretation of the order of
operations so we have two possible
answers for fun I put a poll on YouTube
and I ask people what would you say the
correct answer
is so 16 is what I would say the correct
answer is and on this poll there were
over 169,000 responses so it's not a
scientific poll but it is a lot of
responses overwhelmingly 83% of people
gave the answer of 16
only 5% of people said the answer was
one and 11% of people said there's no
correct answer it's ambiguous and poorly
written presumably they would say the
answer is either 1 or 16 but even then
if you look at modern usage
overwhelmingly most people are taught to
go from left to right and give the
answer of 16 83% is a lot of people to
agree on a divisive topic so let me
address the issue of the people who say
the answer is ambiguous think about the
sentence I saw the man with
binoculars does that mean you use
binoculars to see the man or does it
mean I saw a man who had binoculars
there are two ways to interpret the
sentence but so far I've never seen
anyone say that we need to ban every
single ambiguous sentence in the English
language we deal with ambiguity we
resolve it we interpret things in in
context it's actually a bit of the fun
of life so in order to resolve the
ambiguity you might wonder how might a
calculator evaluate this expression now
if you find a calculator that says
there's no correct answer the correct
answer is this is ambiguous I'll give
you credit but from what I've seen a
calculator will evaluate this expression
and give you an answer it's going to use
its internal set of rules and create a
binary expression tree so let's see how
that might work so we have 8 / 2 *
4 if it does 8 / 2 first we'll have one
thing which is 8 / 2 we take the result
then we create another Branch where we
take that result and multiply it by
four this binary expression tree will
give the result of
16 but there's another way it could have
a binary expression tree it could do 2 /
4 first it'll have 2 and four being
multiplied then we take the result and
then we take 8 divided by that result in
that case you would end up with one so
presumably if there're two different
conventions some people learned it one
way some people learned it another way
you might expect that calculators and
computer programs would have a divide
over this some would say 16 some would
say one so let's just look at what they
actually say so if you input this into
Google it will say the answer is 16 and
it will actually pars it out as 8 / 2
first then multiplied by 4 it will use
this binary expression tree Wolfram
Alpha which usually gets calculations
correct also gives the answer of 16
people who say 16 is the wrong answer
might wonder why are these calculators
giving it well there is a convention and
that's the reason they do give it I also
put this into various computer programs
as 8 divid by 2 multiplied by 4 this is
equal to 16 in Python JavaScript Java C
Excel and most scientific calculators
I've seen if not all scientific
calculators so you might say the answer
is one but it is a practical reality
that if you want to be a programmer if
you want to use spreadsheets if you want
to use calculators most of you are
watching this on a mobile phone you're
watching it on the YouTube app these
things actually do matter in how we
evaluate them so I think it's a
wonderful opportunity for us to explain
the order of operations and what the
correct answer is according to the
modern interpretation of the order of
operations thanks for making us one of
the best communities on YouTube see you
next episode of mind your decisions
where we solve The World's problems one
video at a
time
[Music]
oh